[Música]
fue una de las figuras más influyentes
del siglo XX cambió el curso de uno de
los países más extensos del mundo pero
fue un héroe que derrocó a una tiranía
opresiva o un Villano que la reemplazó
por otra es hora de poner a Lenin en el
estrado en la historia contra Lenin no
orden orden no fue su culpa que la banda
se separará
su señoría este es Vladimir ellish
williano alias Lenin el agitador que
ayudó a derrocar al zar Nicolás II de
Rusia en 1917 y fundó la unión soviética
una de las peores dictaduras del siglo
20 el
zar era un tirano sangriento bajo el
cual las masas trabajaban como esclavos
tonterías la servidumbre ya se había
abolido en 1861 y reemplazado por algo
peor los patrones trataban a los obreros
peor que los antiguos señores feudales
gran diferencia de los señores feudales
estaban siempre allí los trabajadores
rusos trabajaban 11 horas al día y
recibían los salarios más bajos de
Europa
pero el zar aprobó leyes para
protegerlos
de mala gana hizo lo mínimo para evitar
la Revolución y hasta en eso falló
Recuerda lo que pasó en 1905 luego de
que sus tropas dispararan contra los
manifestantes pacíficos el zar puso fin
a la rebelión al presentar una
constitución y un parlamento electo la
duma
mientras conservó el poder absoluto y
disolvía la doma Cuando quería tal vez
habría habido más reformas y los
radicales como Lenin no causaran siempre
tantos disturbios sos señoría su hermano
mayor Alexander ejecutado por el zar
anterior por actividad Revolucionaria e
incluso luego de las reformas Nicolás
continuó la misma represión masiva y las
ejecuciones así como la participación
impopular en la Primera Guerra Mundial
que costó a Rusia tantas vidas y
recursos este
zar no parece un compañero tan
Nicolás segundo se auto condenó por las
malas decisiones pero Lenin no merece
confianza por esto cuando los
levantamientos de febrero de 1917
obligaron alzar a abdicar Lenin seguía
exiliado en Suiza
quien asumió el poder
formó un gobierno provisional dirigido
por Alexander kraenski un fracasado
burgués incompetente incluso lanzó otra
ofensiva fallida durante la Guerra en la
que Rusia ya había perdido mucho en vez
de terminarla como la gente quería
fue un gobierno socialdemócrata
constitucional el más progresista de su
época y podría haber triunfado de no
haber regresado Lenin en abril enviado
por los alemanes para socavar el
esfuerzo de guerra ruso e instigar los
disturbios
calumnia las jornadas de Julio fueron
una reacción espontánea y justificada
contra el fracaso del gobierno yrensky
mostró su verdadera cara al culpar a
Lenin arrestarlo y declarar ilegal a su
partido bolchevique obligándolo
nuevamente a exiliarse
democracia es bueno que el gobierno se
derrumbe por su propia incompetencia y
codicia cuando intentaron un golpe de
estado militar luego tuvieron que pedir
ayuda a los bolcheviques cuando le salió
el tiro por la culata después de eso
Lenin solo tuvo que regresar en Octubre
y hacerse cargo el gobierno fue
derrocado pacíficamente de la noche a la
mañana
pero lo que hicieron los bolcheviques al
Acceder al poder no fue Pacífico a
cuántas personas ejecutaron sin juicio
era necesario asesinar a toda la familia
del zar incluidos los niños
Rusia era atacada por imperialistas
extranjeros que intentaban restaurar al
zar cualquier heredero real sería
reconocido soberano por gobiernos
extranjeros habría sido el fin de lo
conseguido por el pueblo además Lenin no
pudo haber dado la orden pero los
bolcheviques no solo mataron a
imperialistas qué hay de las purgas y
ejecuciones de otros partidos
socialistas y anarquistas antiguos
aliados y la rebelión de tambop en la
que los campesinos que resistían la
confiscación de cereales fueron
asesinados con gases letal y el envío
del ejército para aplastar a los
trabajadores de chromestad que
reclamaban la autogestión democrática
era eso luchar por el pueblo sí las
medidas fueron difíciles pero era un
momento difícil el nuevo gobierno tenía
que garantizar su propia seguridad para
establecer el orden socialista mientras
era atacado por todos lados y que salió
de bueno de ese orden socialista incluso
después de ganada la guerra civil hubo
hambruna represión y millones de
enviados a morir en los campos mientras
stalin el sucesor de Lenin establecía un
culto a la personalidad Y al poder
absoluto Ese no era el plan Allen nunca
le importó el rédito personal hasta sus
enemigos admitieron que él creía en su
causa que vivió modestamente y trabajó
sin descanso desde su juventud hasta su
prematura muerte al ver la ambición de
poder trató de advertir al partido pero
fue demasiado tarde y las décadas de
totalitarismo posteriores puedes
llamarlo así pero fueron los esfuerzos
de Lenin los que cambiaron Rusia en
pocas décadas de una monarquía atrasada
y subdesarrollada repleta de campesinos
analfabetos a una superpotencia
Industrial moderna con una de las
poblaciones mejor formadas del mundo
oportunidades sin precedentes para las
mujeres y algunos de los avances
científicos más importantes del siglo la
vida Puede que no fuera de lujo pero
casi todo el mundo tenía techo y comida
algo que muy pocos países han logrado
esos avances Podrían haber ocurrido
incluso sin Lenin y su régimen represivo
y yo podría haber sido cantante de rock
Pero cómo habría sonado
no podemos estar seguros de cómo habría
ocurrido todo con otras personas en el
poder u otras decisiones pero para
evitar los errores del pasado debemos
poner en tela de juicio a las figuras
históricas
sigue explorando la política del siglo
XX con este video sobre la historia y
las circunstancias que llevaron a Hitler
y al Tercer Reich a subir al poder en
Alemania
[Música]